you know the first I brought this up
with new rock stars the other day Oh
little tease for what's to come
remember in the trailer for Street
Fighter the movie with John Claude they
actually did that whole thing of saying
the character's name of the song first
but it was pretty goofy cuz you know
like the Mortal Kombat just goes like KO
Liu Kang and then Street Fighter would
go like you can really hear it there so
operatic they're like I think there's
thank god yeah
anyway we're gonna watch this gameplay
trailer from Mortal Kombat 11 aftermath
when we saw the reveal trailer I mean we
were like yeah I can't wait for the
gameplay to come out and sure enough
Mortal Kombat standards it's here right
on time let's do this people
[Music]
so your rating is there we are partners
in Earth realms defense
are you also partners in incompetence
looks like Christopher Lambert from
first of all the combat yeah
Jackson Shiva future see it Nana
[Music]
Oh
Oh fanfiction now I can stay accessories
yeah you keep it awesome yeah finish it
I've got a pleasure man it's like pure
Fantasia
love watching them get all banged up so
cool nice nice
I'm excited for this
yeah Tony Gill if you're watching once
it's okay go over to your home corner
your homework verse in each other buddy
no just get a beekeeper outfit lay in
the next room obviously the main
takeaway from this for us
it's Fujin Raijin looks cool man
yeah sometimes when you get like a
sibling character or whatever they're
kind of the same sort of character just
in a different design but he looks like
his moves are gonna be very much
different than right and Shiva
I love the brute force on her looks
excellent absolutely excellent watching
Shiva and Jax go toe-to-toe reminded me
of Mortal Kombat annihilation maybe I
mean obviously it's Robo Cop for us yes
yes that like I grew up on the Robocop
movies 1 to n threats
I've enjoyed the remake also I grew up
on the cartoon there's a Robocop cartoon
that I would watch in grade school it
was on so early at the wake up so early
just to watch this cartoon is it came
out like 5:30 or 6 a.m. and it was
awesome there was a great cartoon I love
everything that they've been doing with
bringing Robocop to life here he looks
like he will not disappoint as this
character because you know I've said
this before a lot of the time you get
excited about
new edition characters are bringing from
like a movie into Mortal Kombat and it
usually sounds really exciting but I
feel like half of the time I don't end
up usually playing as that move because
like it's cool look at I'm glad they're
here but I'm not a big fan of how to use
them they just don't fit in my kind of
style but Robocop you know I didn't know
how he'd move if he'd be like very slow
but he looks like he's moving at a
pretty fast pace I love all the moves
he's got in here of course his badass
gun that comes out from the side blaster
on I don't know the names of it is like
the blaster on his shoulder got a bit of
a jetpack boost at the top has a
flamethrower as well watching him and
teen hundred go toe-to-toe is like fan
fiction for me I believe there's been
comics of that like fan fiction comics
and just watching it come to life here
just brought me a lot of joy John have I
left anything for you I like the way
that this trailer though I mean because
we've seen a lot of Mortal Kombat ads
now and a lot of ads for downloadable
characters and expansion packs and I did
appreciate that they cut this one up in
such a way that they hint it like the
fatalities in the big moments but they
don't actually just give you the whole
thing because as much I love to see
those play out like we did the Joker won
or whatever this one was like okay this
is making me still want to grab the game
so I can get the full force of like a
Robocop fatality or some done yeah it
looks beautiful and I love to the idea
that you can crush Shang Tsung with an
arcade copy of the original like that I
guys just have to imagine it must be so
fun to be one of the developers and one
of the designers yeah work on these
particular games especially in that
times of natis these people were sitting
in a nice calm camp just having fun
being like they can do their thing and
we're just gonna throw in more nerd
characters you know I feel like that's
all Mortal Kombat has to do right now
until Mortal Kombat 12 and then they
have to reinvent the wheel and but it's
just made me want to play as Robocop
that much more I'll give you one thing
to talk about oh it's good to help you
out yeah what's that what's that was
that what did we see in that fatality
with Robocop we saw in that fatality
with Robocop
ed-209 yeah yeah yeah can I get
obliterates somebody and also the
classic that makes pigs yeah yeah yeah I
hope that there are at least a couple
fades out here something like that I
want to see Robocop do his own badass
thing but I would also like the ed-209
version available yeah yeah I mean I
love covering Mortal Kombat because
they're instantly demonetised are like
the best reactions that I love dogs of
money show you guys all right guys who
in this aftermath gameplay trailer
excited you to play as the most was a
Robocop Shiva Fujin leave your thoughts
down below subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification well you know if
I would ever got a video well you know
now the damn cyber lives close too close
to me I might see if there's a way like
we could like gameplay it up do some
Let's Plays over at his home since he's
got a whole set of per se and last but
not least pick Derek Mitchell now Derek
has been a longtime patron of ours love
this gentleman very friendly guy
constantly making jokes about him at his
own expense but I wanted to say that I'm
really proud of the guy he's been
following his passions way more as of
late he's got a really great job in tech
but he just started up his own channel
you could follow his Facebook page where
he just did a live stream on their is
doing gameplays angry Roach gaming he's
gonna be playing Minecraft probably
gonna be branching out and doing more
other things as it's been going he's
been figuring the whole thing out it's
been going great he's been getting a lot
of positive feedback I'm really proud of
this guy because I've known him for
quite a while I know this is one of his
main passions and it always excites me
when an individual goes out there and
follows his passions every little
beginning step is always a major
inspiration in my life so thank you
Derek for inspiring me proud of you for
doing this guys in the link is in the
description box and pink comment
facebook.com slash angry Roach gaming
follow him today
love you buddy